Créanme que no es fácil enfrentarse así
ante un mar de gente.
Imagínense entonces lo que
debe ser sufrir bullying.
Bullying: esas agresiones físicas
o verbales que ocurren en las escuelas
y por eso también se conocen
como acoso escolar.
Uno de los problemas sociales
más discutidos y graves
en los últimos tiempos,
aunque hace 5 o 10 años
creo que pocos o ninguno de nosotros
había escuchado esta palabrita: bullying;
aunque también suele decirse
que esto no es nada nuevo,
que es algo que siempre ocurrió,
y, de hecho, más allá
de la edad que tengamos
todos tenemos alguna experiencia
con este tipo de situaciones,
ya sea porque la vivimos en carne propia
o porque contribuimos a ejercerlas
contra nuestros pobres compañeritos
de entonces en la infancia,
o porque simplemente
la presenciamos.
Antes se llamaba "tomar de punto"
a alguien para burlarse,
ahora se dice bullying.
Yo creo que esto que pasa ahora
y que llamamos bullying
en realidad es algo nuevo.
Tiene semejanzas con lo que pasaba antes
pero no es exactamente lo mismo.
Y esto por varios motivos.
Primero: antes no teníamos
una palabra para nombrarlo,
para nombrar el fenómeno o, por lo menos,
no era esta palabra: bullying.
No era noticia
ni se discutía en los medios,
no se promulgaban leyes
para cohibirlo o penalizarlo.
Claro que podía ser motivo de sufrimiento
para mucha gente, y de hecho lo era,
pero se pensaba que era algo
más o menos normal,
una consecuencia indeseada,
un efecto colateral
de la convivencia escolar,
pero no tan grave.
Algunos incluso podían pensar que eso
contribuía a la educación de los chicos.
Pero hay algo importante y es que
en esa misma época, hasta hace poco,
otros dramas escolares
se consideraban mucho más serios
que esas "peleítas" sin importancia
en los recreos y en los pasillos.
Me refiero a las amonestaciones,
las expulsiones, incluso las malas notas.
Tanto los chicos, como los maestros,
los padres y la sociedad en general,
pensaban que eso era mucho más importante
que lo que ahora llamamos bullying.
Aunque ahora tiende a ser al revés:
las malas notas
y las reprimendas disciplinarias
parece que son cada vez menos graves
y este nuevo fenómeno del bullying
ocupa un papel cada vez más central.
Entonces hay un movimiento simultáneo
y complementario
que sucede al mismo tiempo.
Por un lado: los motivos tradicionales
de humillación escolar,
que son los castigos
aplicados por una autoridad,
como un docente o un directivo
a los alumnos que hicieron
algo considerado incorrecto,
algo prohibido por los reglamentos
o considerado que no se debe hacer,
como portarse mal o no estudiar,
por un lado esto pierde peso;
y, por otro lado, ganan prioridad
nuevos motivos de humillación escolar.
Que son estos castigos que
los alumnos se aplican entre sí
por muy diversos motivos pero casi siempre
por algo relacionado con el aspecto físico
o con la personalidad de la víctima.
Si esto sucede,
la pregunta es: ¿por qué?
¿Por qué esta transformación
en nuestros valores?
Yo creo que se trata de
un gran cambio histórico
sobre el cual vale la pena pensar.
Pensamos que por un lado en
esos motivos de humillación escolar,
en los conflictos escolares tradicionales:
amonestaciones, expulsiones, malas notas,
lo que opera es la culpa,
culpa por haber hecho algo malo.
La culpa es una emoción interna, privada
se refiere a un conflicto moral,
a un drama de cada uno consigo mismo,
por haber hecho algo
que no solo los reglamentos
dicen que está prohibido
porque es incorrecto,
sino que todos piensan
que está mal, incluso yo.
Yo me siento culpable
porque hice algo malo.
En el caso del bullying,
no es la culpa lo que está en juego
sino otro tipo de emoción: la vergüenza.
No es exactamente lo mismo,
es bastante distinta.
La vergüenza es una emoción pública,
no se refiere a un drama privado
de cada uno consigo mismo,
por haber hecho algo malo.
En el caso de la vergüenza
el problema no soy yo, sino los otros,
los demás, la mirada de los demás,
que me juzga de un modo incorrecto,
injusto, a veces cruel,
más allá de que yo tenga la culpa o no
de haber hecho algo malo,
en general no tengo culpa de nada;
son los otros que ejercen sobre mí
esa mirada cruel.
Es una transformación del equilibrio,
pasa a ser más importante
la vergüenza que la culpa
y esta es una clave para entender
por qué están cambiando
nuestras prioridades.
Porque me parece que la mirada ajena,
la mirada del otro,
que obviamente siempre fue importante,
últimamente ganó un peso desmesurado,
desmedido tal vez,
sobre todo en el momento de juzgar
quién es cada uno y cuánto vale.
Y esto no siempre fue así,
por eso digo que es
un gran cambio histórico
y claro que es un cambio muy complejo
que no es de ahora,
que viene gestándose hace décadas
y que está terminando de consumarse,
está cristalizando ahora.
Creo que uno de los ingredientes
más importantes de esta transformación
es el abandono de la idea
de interioridad.
¿Qué es eso?
Fue una creencia fundamental durante
los 200 años que nos precedieron,
siglos XIX y XX: la convicción
de que existía la vida interior,
algo esencial pero invisible a los ojos,
que se creía que definía a cada uno
de una forma mucho más profunda
y verdadera que las vanas apariencias.
Esas apariencias se consideraban
vanas y también falsas, frívolas,
como algo menor, sin importancia,
comparado con toda la contundencia
de esa verdad o belleza interior.
Todo esto son valores y creencias
que todavía permanecen entre nosotros
pero que estamos abandonando.
Por ejemplo, las vanas apariencias
me parece bastante claro
que ya no son tan vanas:
pensemos en todo el fenómeno
del culto al cuerpo que se desarrolló
en las últimas décadas,
la importancia de la imagen personal,
del aspecto físico,
el tema de los gimnasios, de los
tratamientos estéticos, todo eso.
También importa mucho y cada vez
se da más énfasis a lo que se ve.
Y se pierde esa noción de que
lo más importante de cada uno
es algo que no se ve,
pero que no son las tripas,
sino algo inmaterial
como el alma o el espíritu.
Parece que cada vez creemos menos en eso
y más en lo que los demás pueden ver,
lo que mostramos, lo que hacemos,
y en función de estas transformaciones
los otros nos juzgan a partir de
lo que ven y menos a partir de esa noción
de que hay algo dentro, una interioridad
etérea, medio victoriana anticuada,
que sería más verdadera
que los actos y las apariencias.
Junto con esto aparecen una serie
de indicios de transformaciones
y uno de ellos seria la autopromoción,
las tácticas o técnicas de autopromoción
que hoy están por todas partes
y que hasta hace poco
se considerarían algo de mal gusto.
Pensemos por ejemplo
en la obsesión por conquistar
la mayor cantidad de seguidores
o de "me gusta";
esto también para probar que
uno es alguien, que existe,
que tiene valor
y que merece ser admirado.
Todo el fenómeno de las redes sociales
podría ser visto también
como una prueba de esta transformación,
el éxito de las redes sociales
de Internet.
Así como un conjunto, una infinidad
de síntomas, fenómenos contemporáneos
que van desde los tatuajes
hasta las cirugías plásticas,
pasando por los reality shows
y por el bullying.
Creo que pensando
en este contexto más amplio
no sorprende que hoy el bullying
se haya transformado en algo tan serio,
cuando las amonestaciones y malas notas
son cada vez menos graves.
Parece que la culpa perdió buena parte
de su eficacia moralizadora.
La culpa ya no es tan eficaz
como la vergüenza
para producir efectos en nuestras vidas.
Y esto claro que es muy complicado,
porque exige la gestión de dos vertientes
que parecen contradictorias:
por un lado tenemos que exponernos,
tenemos que mostrarnos,
los demás tienen que ver lo que somos,
cómo somos y lo que hacemos,
tenemos que cultivar y divulgar
nuestra imagen.
Pero por otro lado está siempre
el riesgo de que esa mirada ajena
no nos devuelva admiración sino rechazo,
burla, o que nos ignoren, también.
Nos hemos vuelto
más vulnerables a la mirada ajena
por ese mismo motivo.
Pensemos también en la complicación
que es el "cyberbullying",
cuando estas burlas o difamaciones
se diseminan por las redes,
YouTube, Facebook, etc.
y lo que antes solía ser privado,
limitado al grupito de conocidos
o protegido por las paredes
de la escuela o de la casa
de repente se expone
ante millones de personas.
Todos los saben, entonces
la vergüenza se hace terrible,
mucho más grave y no tenemos
dónde refugiarnos,
ni dentro de uno mismo,
ni en la intimidad,
ni siquiera soñando con escaparse
a una isla desierta
--que cada vez existen menos
o no existen ya, al menos no sin wifi--.
Parece que esta idea de que
el infierno son los otros
se ha vuelto más verdadera ahora,
en la era de la conexión permanente
y de los perfiles siempre visibles
en miles de pantallas
y con esta dependencia que desarrollamos
con respecto al botón "me gusta",
ese clic mágico que esperamos
que todos nos concedan
ante cualquier "selfie" o lo que sea que
posteamos con respecto a nosotros mismos.
Si todo este cambio histórico
está sucediendo
con estas consecuencias y efectos,
la pregunta sería: ¿qué hacemos?
¿Esto es mejor o peor que antes?
¿Es bueno o malo?
¿Cómo lo solucionamos?
La mala noticia es que no tengo solución,
pero creo que tengo algunas pistas.
Me parece que tanto
la culpa como la vergüenza
son mecanismos de control social,
y el hecho de que la culpa esté perdiendo
buena parte de su vigor ahora
y que la vergüenza se esté magnificando,
esto no es ni bueno ni malo en sí.
Pero debemos tenerlo en cuenta,
es un dato que significa
que las cosas ya cambiaron,
y si seguimos pensando
que lo que pasa ahora
es lo mismo que pasaba antes
y lo tratamos de solucionar
como si fuera lo mismo,
probablemente no vamos
a llegar muy lejos.
Esto es lo que les quería contar.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)